foreign
a very big warm welcome to everyone the
webinar will be stalking starting in
just about five more minutes so hang
tight and we'll see you in a bit
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello and a warm welcome and joining us
for the president's Design Awards third
webinar in the education and career
series beyond beautiful spaces a career
in spatial design my name is Juliana and
I'm very happy to be your host for today
so of course the president's design
award or PDA for short is Singapore's
highest Accolade for designers and
Designs across all disciplines the PDA
education and career series offers
students fresh graduates and
professionals interested in a career in
spatial and interior design and up close
and personal opportunity to dialogue
with the recipients of the president's
design award so the first two additions
that we did in the early part of the
Year focus on visual communication as
well as product and Industrial design
respectively and it featured recipients
from Design Studios such as kinetic
Singapore and Larry Nation young design
and companies like Dell both of these
webinar recordings can be phone on dsg's
YouTube page so feel free to check that
out after this session for more exciting
updates on PDA as well as other DSG
programs all you have to do is to follow
design Singapore console on Instagram
for all of your exciting updates but for
today's webinar I do have a couple of
house rules just to keep everything
session running as smoothly as possible
firstly please be informed that this
webinar will be recorded and that your
microphones will be muted throughout
this session however you are most
welcome to submit questions through our
Zoom q and a function and our speakers
will try their best to address them
during the question and answer segment
later on and if you encounter any
technical issues at all please ping our
technical team through the zoom chat
function
so in today's webinar our panel of
speakers will share about how they
kick-started their Design Careers and
how you can plan for yours what is the
role of a spatial or interior designer
like and how has it evolved over the
years what are the current opportunities
as well as challenges for fresh
graduates and young designers in the
field today or how can new designers
actually build up a portfolio these are
just some of the many questions that our
panel of speakers may just be tackling
today
so for now it is my pleasure to
introduce the recipients on our panel
firstly we have architect Lim Kun Park
founding principal of Park and
Associates and PDA 2015 design of the
year for the architect's office at Kim
Yan Road
we also have architect Collins Yar
founder director of Ministry of design
and PDA 2008 and 2006 design of the year
for BBH office in a warehouse and the
new Majestic Hotel
finally we have architect Uncle Sheng
director at liquor Architects and Joshua
komarov design consultant at lekker
Architects PDA 2015 design of the year
for the caterpillars call although
unfortunately architect Uncle Shing and
Joshua komarov they're not able to join
us in person today but we have a
recording of their sharing so if you
have any questions for the both of them
please feel free to still submit your
questions via the Q a function and our
PDA Secretariat will share their
responses in a post-event Roundup
emailer after the event
I'm happy to announce that our moderator
for today is Mr fan who is course chair
for diploma in interior design in
Singapore Polytechnic as well as vice
president of the Society of interior
designers Singapore but as usual before
we begin the session we'll actually love
to find out more from you here today say
for our audience out there we're going
to run a poll tell us who you are and
what Fields you're currently studying or
working in okay the two questions will
soon pop up on your screen you can let
us know whether you're a student or
perhaps you're a fresh graduate joining
us here today you've got one or two
years of working experience or maybe
you're like a veteran you've already
been in this field for a long time just
let us know so we have a better idea of
who we're speaking to today
something else we'll also like to find
out is which field you're in it could be
a mixture you can select multiple
options I know many of you are very
multi-talented out there we've got
spatial and interior design which is
what we'll be speaking about today
architecture product and Industrial
design UI ux design viscom or
advertising maybe you're in other design
disciplines or maybe you're not even in
the design field but you're interested
to find out more maybe make a career
switch and that's why you're here today
so feel free to submit your answers via
the poll when we have a better idea we
might be speaking to it might help to
kind of Channel those questions during
our q a and for our speakers sharing as
well so I'm going to give you a couple
more seconds or a little bit more time
to fill in those questions
whether we're going to be seeing more
students
or maybe you're actually watching this
from the office right now it is 4 P.M
after all
I wouldn't be surprised to see that
so let us know which design Fields
you're in we have a good amount of
responses let me just take a look right
now okay
so at this point of time I do see that
we have a huge amount 58 of you are
actually working professionals again I
think my guess was right you all are
either working from home at this point
in time or maybe you are watching this
from the studio from the office it's
great to also see lots of students in
here 39 are currently students
um also it seems like the targeting has
done very well we've got a staggering 72
percent of people in spatial as well as
interior design and also a very relevant
feel in architecture we got 29 of you as
well for the rest of the mix we've got
you know less than 10 percent
um in product and Industrial we've got
UI ux design or even for the non-design
disciplines nine percent of people so
that's an interesting statistic to see
but again I think it's very encouraging
to see a lot of spatial and interior
design professionals and students
joining us in this webinar today I hope
you will have lots of takeaways from our
panel here today
so finally there is one last question I
would love for you to vote on please
rank the key topics that you would like
our moderator to see you later to focus
on during the Q and a segment so we'll
love to find out what is it that you're
most passionate about or like you want
to discuss the most so we have three
options for you to pick from
whether it's the evolution of interior
design in Singapore as well as
throughout the world the employer's wish
list for prospective hires and how to
build up a solid portfolio I imagine all
the students will immediately click that
one or perhaps this guiding principles
to balance demands across projects while
keeping in mind the objective of
sustainability and to design for
positive impact I mean to be honest all
of these are so relevant can you pick
more than one
I feel like everybody's going to be
picking picking everything at this point
in time students number two for sure so
we're gonna give you a little bit more
time to submit the options or try to
make judea's job a little bit easier
maybe he'll have a very very clear
picture of uh the kind of questions
we'll be we'll be looking forward to
later on in this session again a bit
more time for you to think about it
choose the option you would like to hear
about the most and I will be announcing
the poll results in a bit
again I still think that these are also
relevant okay but we do have uh the poll
results coming in
to say I don't know how to help you out
on this one
kind of a spread out
um in option one the evolution of
interior design in Singapore 35
option two all our students clicking on
that 132 percent and option three
talking about sustainability and
positive impact 34 I guess you just it
just means that our speakers as well as
our moderator would have to discuss all
of these topics on hand here today all
in the 30 something percent everybody is
interested to just find out all the
information they can get in our webinar
here today so just yeah I trust that
you're gonna do a great job in that
session later on but for now our
audience thank you so much for your
participation and for voicing out what
you love to hear now that we've gotten
to know you so much better I'm gonna go
right into the sharing by our speakers
so without further Ado I'd like to
welcome our very first speaker for today
here's Punk he is the founding principal
of Park and Associates Carl believes
that good design should be relevant yet
possess a sense of timelessness that can
withstand ever-changing Trends so
through through a mass experience in
designing and managing projects of
varied projects a punk has developed a
keen interest in people and The Human
Experience in architecture he Endeavors
to create designs that retain a
humanistic touch in this increasingly
detached world with that framing every
piece of design Creed thereafter is
carefully customized and crafted to
resonate with the users Parks
architectural and interior Pursuits have
since guarded numerous architecture and
Design Awards earning him critical
Acclaim locally and internationally so
now that we heard all about him park
over to you please
thank you very much thank you very much
Juliana for the very flattering
introduction thank you and uh welcome
everyone
um nice that you listen in and take an
interest in our journey my journey as
architect
um my name is Park founder and principal
Park associate architects
I shall start my uh
talk
um with my first awareness of design as
a possible career path and that was when
I was back in my junior college Years I
grew up in a small City in Malaysia and
in those times there was no such thing
as a career counselor in schools hand
hence I knew very little about the
possibilities in the universities
I had almost zero understanding of
architecture as a course in the uni and
how I stumbled upon my first inclination
towards design was during my a level
General Paper examination
I've always been a very big student in
GDP uh barely made it through the grades
in my two years in JC so during the
actual a11 exam I was as usually a stump
just staring at the choices of difficult
topics that center around politics
economics philosophy and religion and
among the options one odd topic stood up
is titled how to decorate your ideal
home
and there was a topic I wrote about
and when the result came back I actually
got a distinction for the first time in
my whole JC career and with that at the
back of my mind I discovered that
architecture could be a course that was
uh be interested in flipping through the
prospectus of the university and us at a
time
and here I am
I started the architecture in nus in
1985 I went on to do my part two in
Bartlett School architecture and another
year in Sheffield eventually where
that's where I graduated I came back to
Singapore after graduation work in a
local practice I went on to uh I went to
China for a few years
and I came back to the same phone that
started with
um before actually starting part
Associates in 1999
so
um if you want to ask have I always been
ambitious young architect with the
burning desire to start my own practice
about answer is actually no and the
reason why that happened was because my
employer at the time very successful
architect but he was diverting most of
his focus and attention into development
and investment where it naturally made a
lot more money and neglecting the
architectural practice and I was
beginning to feel quite disheartened
about the whole process and and also
come along for me to take on the house
commission and I figured I could survive
on the fee for a year on my own and
without much planning or thinking or
worrying about what's a pitfall and I
took the first step and started my own
company
and this is uh if you worth mentioning
uh
then at the beginning of one's career uh
it's actually great to have friends to
bounce ideas off and give each other a
different perspective in work and life
in general in that regards I had a good
fortune to have met Colin who is also
speaking today among others in my
formative years Colleen who is also
starting out about the same time as I
did if I'm not wrong we've been good
friends and Council since
they even have the whole photograph you
see on screen now there was me in my
geeky 90s outfit and of course Colleen
already looking like calling of today
in the photo
[Music]
with a lot of hard work over the years
the first started to gain Traction in
the market and we continue to grow and
grow until year two zero zero seven at
the time we had about 20 offers in
office that was when I entered one of
the lowest point of architectural
Journey
um November 2007 for those who have been
through it uh that was when the global
financial crisis hit
well if you for the younger folks if you
recall back when we were first
encountered with the crisis of Kobe
pandemic uh in 2-0 2020 early 2020 the
fear the uncertainty and the worries
about what it could do to the economy
well in 2007 they were multi-fold of
what you felt uh they were the real deep
fear and impact was real
uh it didn't go away like kovit this
time it stood there for a long time it
was it was very bad and it was sudden
and within a month almost all the
project had to be literally suspended
and the suspension was so called
indefinite we do not know when it's
coming back it was terrifying time
survival was in question
not to be overly dramatic but at the
darkest hour when I knew that I would
have difficulty paying my guys a
subsequent month uh I received a call
from a friend who had the scope of work
that he didn't know how to define
then Singapore was building the major
building a major International theme
park for the first time and it was Bank
Road and the government was on its back
and it was the very field project that
was running at the time
they gathered the best expertise from
all over for the project there was
concept designer from the US a Singapore
architect rights from the Netherlands
and the tracks for the ride from Belgium
and many other supplies from all over
the world and he had a very capable
installer who is very very Japanese but
the problem they had was to have to get
all them on the same page
and that was the scope that it needed to
feel
I put together a logical response
started on the project
within the week
and thankfully we completed Universal
Studio Singapore in good time which
years all over and it was how a window
was opened for me
to a whole new field of work so part
associate entered the timber industry so
beside architecture we became known we
become a known name in that impact
business internationally
and we have completed projects all over
the world from Florida to Shanghai from
Tokyo to Dubai
and uh fast forward to
2013 there was another Milestone year
for us we move into our new office at
kimyam Road
uh
we conceived office with the same empty
office
we wanted to redefine what the workspace
could be
and it was very well received by the
design industry it was also a PDA
acknowledged our achievement and awarded
us accolades design of the year
so these are shots of our current office
as it stands
roundabout 2017 we begin to have small
offices in Bangkok Manila China and the
US
yeah
we have completed many projects by now I
shall speak briefly on a few today one
of the Highlight was completing nanyang
girls high it was not an easy project
but it was definitely worth it we want
the project via competition and we
actually disregard key aspects of the
competition uh brief and ended up
winning the project possibly because we
had disregarded the competition brief I
think
um the design challenge many of Moe's
conventions and reconception and we had
many conversations with them to try to
convince them that it's okay or is even
good to think outside the box and I
think eventually they relented and let
us do the project as it stood today
I think this sense of Entry
establishment is something we believe in
and encourage in office
after the project completed we were
invited back
to an onion
in one of the
assemblies we are presented with a
special gift from the student
which is this video
as you can tell from this video it was a
real labor loved by a lot of hard work
by the students
[Music]
too much
cause I got that sunshine
where to hunt when I'm when I'm getting
new clothes
[Music]
well you get you get a picture the
Gratitude from the Stephen and seeing
how they enjoy the architecture and
today is very moving I have to admit
that being surprised by the video in the
assembly and watching it for the first
time on stage was emotional to say the
least
and in this project we challenge local
taboo against a classroom being in the
basement
it was a tough job convincing the
ministry but I think it turned out
beautifully and this is being a basement
lineup one can tell there is a basement
classrooms
and the competition brief originally
called for two blocks of four-story
building and we thought it was brutal to
kill the green and we figured out a way
to return the green to both the students
as well as anybody driving along Daniel
Road I think it turned out quite nicely
another project uh was an interesting
Tau showroom we recently completed I
won't go through the design Concept in
too much detail but I just
want to share that we want it to be a
place that opens the imagination for
customers from all walks of life and
design should be accessible by uh
everybody not just the design
professionals
and we wanted the the showroom to
um to go beyond purely transactional
setting so I wanted to be a place
invigorating and memorable and uh
empowering experience for everyone to
visit the place
houses shall end my talk on this note
while we have gone quite a bit since we
started more than 20 years ago but we
still love designing houses because
houses usually have more room for
expression and exploration that is for
start but more importantly houses is a
chance for us to forge new partnership
with the owner over the years and we
have built many beautiful friendships in
the process as well so houses are not
just a commodity where we are concerned
on this note I shall hand it back to
Jelena
all right thank you very much Paul I
especially love that little snipper you
added in about how you won the project
by challenging the project ask as well
as the relationships that you fought
with all of your clients so I imagine we
might be seeing some questions regarding
that in the Q a segment later but we'll
see how it goes our very next speakers
we have Architects ankershing and Joshua
komara from Lego Architects they're a
group of designers and architects who
are fascinated by the power of space to
engage create formative moments to
provide a stage for public life so their
interest does lie in projects with big
Ambitions from buildings that provide
inclusion
neighborhoods that encourage walking and
socializing to dream like retail
experiences that are exciting and
transformative on crushing is an
architect and educator she studied at
Harvard College and Harvard Graduate
School of Design taking degrees in the
fields of Fine Art architecture and
Landscape architecture at the National
University of Singapore Department of
architecture she teaches design as an
associate professor in practice and is
the program director for the
undergraduate Bachelor of Arts in
architecture program
for her work as an architect with
leckers she was selected as one of
urea's 20 under 45 in 2017.
Joshua komarov is a design consultant at
Lake Architects and an assistant
professor in the urban studies program
at Yale nus College he studied at
Amherst College and Harvard Graduate
School of Design taking degrees in the
fields of literature architecture and
Landscape architecture
in 2009 Joshua completed a PhD in
cultural geography at University of
California Los Angeles writing about
haunted Landscapes and urban memory in
Singapore so we'll now play the
recording from Shing as well as Joshua
hi we're Josh and Ching from lekka
Architects thanks to our friends at the
PDA for inviting us to speak at this
education and career webinar
so the prompt for today's session is
beyond Aesthetics and the question here
we think is not one of rejecting
Aesthetics everyone knows that design is
an aesthetic practice
rather than this asks how can design go
beyond primarily aesthetic or formal
concerns to have a greater impact
that is what makes a design relevant
impactful why does the public seem to
care about one project and then not
spend much time thinking about another
Josh and I think that there are several
ways to answer this question but we want
to share one answer with you today based
on the experience of our practice and
projects and this has to do with the
user the typical subject of design the
protagonists and how they're assumed or
imagined when we make things
and the message here is not to be
user-centric so much of design method no
matter how user-centric assumes a
normative experience we assume
tolerances for stimulation legibility
and desire but because we work for
diverse publics these assumptions are
usually false
so for this reason we can make our work
relevant we can go beyond Aesthetics by
simply expanding our definition of our
users and most importantly try to
understand the experience that they have
through our design of environments
products and communication now that's
not an easy thing to do but it's worth
doing because when the definition of the
user changes all of design changes
Innovation happens without our even
trying new worlds emerge and they emerge
for all of us because there's another
Simple Truth which is that there is no
typical user this old Workhorse
Assumption of design has always been
wrong almost no one is physically or
neurologically typical in some neutral
sense so we're going to show a few
examples from our work where
breakthroughs occurred and the work
gained relevance based upon some new
understandings of the user
our friends at PDA asked us to talk
today about how we began our careers in
design actually we began ours in the
wrong way we did this by doing the
rightest thing that you can do we did
really well in school we went to the
Harvard design school right and it's
this Mecca of design where you learn to
make the most sophisticated work and
study under the best architects in the
world et cetera et cetera and the last
20 years of our practice has been
actually about unlearning what we
learned there because what we learned
there was that the design product in our
case the building is the protagonist of
the design process it's the end result
and its own embodied Excellence will be
self-evident in fact we now see design
in a completely different way as a
medium buildings are a medium landscape
products Graphics these are all media
architectural design is not the end goal
for us these days it's simply a device
to embody social meanings to respond to
broader conditions and to enable human
potentials and interestingly this is how
much of the public views design also
Aesthetics have in some ways become a
huge social problem and we would argue
that social social media and the
internet have created a huge aesthetic
fatigue right and this is why the public
have begun to understand design through
Concepts like Cottage core and dark
Academia and these speak to questions of
who the user can be and how the design
can enable their aspirations and values
so in a sense this is very similar to
what we were trying to do at a project
like this this was Singapore's first
inclusive school now a time today here
is short so that's a lot of detail about
this online and I won't go into it too
deeply but the concept here was to try
to do away with anything that was part
of the Traditional School room as we
know it why this had to do with the
students who attend this school they
hail from across the autism spectrum
this means that some are hypersensitive
meaning that the slightest visual or
auditory stimuli in the environment are
highly disturbing but others are exactly
the opposite uh hypostensitive meaning
that they need intense stimuli to get
going and to learn some are
uncomfortable with doors and thresholds
and enclosures and others really need
these to feel safe for each the
experience of a design space is entirely
different so there's no typical autistic
person and at the same time there are
students with motor neurological issues
and with Visual and hearing impairments
so at the back of this room here you can
see tables and these were required for
licensing but we simply pushed them to
the back of the room and this is because
kids in wheelchairs can't use these
tables instead the room was imagined as
what you see in the front here a kind of
campfire or storytelling Circle and the
tent is here in case any of the kids
feel overstimulated and need to limit
their visual or spatial feel to relax
this is why we need to have a space that
is really a whole set of telescoping
spaces of different scales so we wind up
with little holes and Nooks like this
and these are actually essential for
certain kids to be able to occupy this
room at all when we begin to do this the
furniture starts to become space making
and we get rooms within Furniture within
rooms some of the classrooms here are
actually made using huge soft blocks and
this is so that the students again with
all of their different and conflicting
needs can each day create the classroom
that they feel most comfortable learning
in and what we see here is a really
interesting principle that took us years
to learn no single space with a single
design can be inclusive because
different users have conflicting needs
so one space must have the potential to
be many and to change on the Fly sort of
like a theater space which you can see
in this image which can always be
reconfigured
we can see the same effect here this is
the library of the canossian school
where many of the children have hearing
disabilities the wall is full of alcoves
also but you can also see this Labyrinth
across the floor
in here the acoustic conditions are
really different from a larger space
it's very much dampened and it allows
kids with hearing impairment to read
comfortably what's interesting in this
room again is that it becomes a kind of
layering of different rooms it's
striated and not necessarily internally
coherent
this is from the same project what we
find fascinating about this is that the
needs of the inhabitants really Foss the
environment to involve to evolve into
something new a single room is not just
one thing it starts to have multiple
overlapping and collage like layers
and we start to see this wild profusion
of different modes of communication
everything from fridge magnet poetry to
storytelling to Shadow puppetry the
forms and functions of this space get
really matched up and complex and the
kind of creative chaos that is happening
in the social layer as kids simply
figure out how to get along in a way
that doesn't leave anyone out left to
their own devices they will do that
and then in some cases the way that the
space is inhabited just radically
changes what you see here is a quiet
room space at the national museum for
individuals and families with sensory
processing issues and people with these
issues are just incredibly sensitive in
a way that most of us aren't the
vibrations from HVAC systems will feel
like the room is shaking the background
hum of architecture or the city around
would be deafening and make it
impossible to think surfaces will be way
too tactile and stimulating in fact very
few spaces have been purpose designed
for these folks until recently usually
it was some back room or even a broom
closet with carpeting up the walls and
this here is one of the first and we're
finishing now a larger one in kazuo
sejuma's garage Museum in Moscow and
again you can see that the requirement
of this group transforms this design to
have a space that's small soft
acoustically separated from the
building's mechanical systems it's far
more comfortable when it's curvilinear
and the space is carefully calibrated to
diffuse a consistent color tone through
indirect light so different colors will
help to dampen hypersensitivity or to
energize the hyposensitive
and sometimes considering the needs of a
specific User Group may result in a
project that does not involve designing
spaces at all when we started to look
into how designed for persons with
dementia work we realize that actually
the more that one can maintain their
existing familiar spaces the better and
this is because sudden changes in
routine and environment can speed up the
progression of the disease
so the key challenge is how to support
people with dementia in their carers as
they continue to live at home as their
needs change the furniture and their
Arrangements have to adapt also
so we proposed a series of hacks to Ikea
furniture to support these needs in this
book of hacks and explanatory essays and
interviews is available for download in
its entirety at hackcare.org so please
do go and check it out if you're
interested
sometimes the designer may need to work
for users that are not human at all and
this is something we need to think about
in the time of climate change this is a
plant that we see often in the botanics
or around Singapore to heliconia they
aren't native but they have been very
popular here and so they're super common
and in their native context these are
pollinated by hummingbirds hummingbirds
pollinate while hovering they beat their
wings very quickly to stay in one place
but in Singapore we have olive-backed
Sunbirds which are close relatives of
the hummingbird but with an important
difference Sunbirds perch in order to
pollinate and the ecologist Richard
corlett has observed Sunbirds in
Singapore trying to pollinate heliconias
but they can't because they can't find a
place to stand and this tiny problem of
bird ergonomics has a huge impact
because it means that heliconias here
cannot produce without human
intervention and this is hugely
unsustainable
so in design research for arcasia The
Architects Regional Council of Asia we
attempted to make tiny biodegradable
platforms for the heliconia that will
allow Sunbirds to perch and to pollinate
without human help it's a little Bridge
until some genetic adaptation makes
these work a little bit better in our
environment
now who's the user here is it the bird
uh the plant the novel ecosystem that's
emerging in Singapore as a result of
human disturbance going back to Colonial
times it's not clear but what's obvious
is that our approach to landscape design
has to change in this context and we're
only able to make this leap when we
think about this Enigma of who or what
that user is
okay so hopefully we've made this quick
simple point clear and something that
we'd like to point out just by way of
closing is that in fact in popular forms
of imagination and we would call these
design also we've been making things for
unusual users needs for ages and without
making a big noise about it it's largely
been a professionalized design that
we've shifted toward producing for a
fictional typical user at an industrial
scale so as most of you will recognize
these are everyday things for ghosts
shoes cars architecture Etc and the data
perhaps an extreme example of the
atypical user but because there are
strong traditional ideas of the
afterlife the design for these folks is
very clearly understood
so we've dabbled a little bit in this
area well we were invited to do so by an
art curator and again when we tried to
Think Through what a home might be for a
lineage of ancestors the world changed
we wanted it to have a sense of History
hence it's a shop house but in any
family there are more and more and more
ancestors all the time so this meant
that an intergenerational home had to be
huge like an endlessly growing Tower
obviously we didn't figure out how to
design for the afterlife and the result
looked super odd but we came up against
again is the simple but often ignored
point that we're making today in the
practitioners search for forms and
solutions there's an elusive fit between
design products and users and when
understood in new and precise ways this
is powerful for carrying us beyond the
aesthetic and into new worlds of making
and thinking thanks for listening
thank you very much sing and Joshua I
hope you've enjoyed this sharing as much
as I did so that truly brought about a
lot of insight regarding design of
spaces or designer products to promote
inclusivity for people on this Earth or
even Beyond so also speaking today last
but not least we have Colin Sia founder
director of Ministry of design so he is
architecturally trained in the US and
licensed in Singapore Colin honed his
sensibilities working for the likes of
ram cool house and Daniel liver skin he
also spent four years at the National
University of Singapore's Department of
architecture researching design pedagogy
and serving as a design critic as
Ministry of Design's founder and
director of design Colin has been named
designer of the Year by International
Design Awards USA 2010. he is also a
three-time grand prize winner of the
gold key award the highest International
hospitality de Accolade he is named Hong
Kong's perspective's 40 under 40
Architects Marcus cooperation Foundation
prize 2007 emerging architect with
potential for greatness and recognized
as rising star in architecture by Monaco
Colin has been a juror for the inaugural
Design Awards a global advisor for
leading Services manufacturer
Constantino and invited by the Singapore
tourism board to redefine Singapore as a
destination for 2020 and beyond that is
a whole lot of awards and accolades so
Colin now that we've heard all about you
the time is yours
thank you so much uh for the warm
welcome and also a huge shout out to our
good friends Park uh and also Josh and
Ching fellow allies and and uh so
jealous in this design world it's really
great to have friends like you guys
especially when things get tough and uh
knock back a beer or two when things are
going well so
um today I would love to share with you
uh my little trajectory into the design
world and also just one project it's not
a PDA winner but we hope one day it will
be the the firms called Ministry of
design a little bit so tongue and cheek
we live in Singapore where there's a
Ministry for everything so we thought
why not call it Ministry of design and
when we call some clients the
secretaries will pick out the phone and
get a bit of a scare because they think
maybe they've done something wrong the
ministry of design is calling you know
is my building the wrong color or
something uh so does that and also I
think uh I intentionally named it to
represent a group of people not just one
voice uh but the the group of people who
are now a minister of design are made up
of a lot of talented individuals much of
them like you guys in the audience out
there uh you know they're ones with
students they are now professionals but
all of them very passionate like you are
about design and also yeah the other
reason we called it many of Ministry of
designers because I think design is a
gift that some of us have been given and
it's a way to minister and to make the
world a better place through design
um my journey to design was not at all
intentional uh I never dreamed of being
an architect or designer I didn't really
have any influences in my life or people
who steered me that way
um and I think I was only exposed to
creative gestures which were more
bite-sized like you know picking up a
camera I had dreams of being a
photographer in fact I I did do a quite
a bit of photography for for fashion
designer as well as architectural
photography and also at the theater
directing but none of those things
really kind of satisfied the same way uh
which
um I was looking for in a discipline
which I hadn't actually been able to
solve a picture in my mind yeah but one
day there was this sort of epiphany that
architecture should be it and some of
you may just chance upon that as well
one day you'll wake up and go this is
the thing for me that's what happened
and I spent five years in architecture
school abroad and did multiple
internships and spent quite a number of
years teaching in anywhere else and all
this was a good foundation to creating
Ministry of design which has been 18
years in the making now together with
about 30 of my colleagues over three
offices and it's been lovely difficult
challenging but very rewarding Journey
as well the
thing which underpins our work is not so
much a style or an aesthetic but it's
really an attitude or mindset and if we
were to solve summarize it very simply
in a graphic it would be to question to
disturb and redefine uh and What on
earth does that mean and really the
the attitude resonates and was
germinated when we began to realize that
a lot of the clients who are having our
projects we were having all had very
starting points where the mindset was
rooted in convention and I think we
needed to sort of uproot ourselves from
uh the things that have gone before us I
mean convention obviously is important
and has relevance because it works and
it has to work for a while now but with
the Changing Times and culture we
recognize that what used to be relevant
may not be relevant tomorrow so today's
relevance needs to be questioned for
tomorrow's application so we like to
always challenge convention in whatever
level sometimes the projects allow us to
ask very deep and fundamental questions
other times it's a downstream and it
takes on smaller forms but not any less
meaningful and then through the attitude
of always wanting to question we then uh
disturb convention through a lot of uh
you know rigorous uh uh thoughtful
Innovative work uh where we iterate
design to refine it and get it better
and then hopefully we come up with
something that's really fine so I'd like
to give you an example of a project
which has done we feel just that and
it's for the client City Bank
um and it was the competition which we
were invited to and we had never done
any work in this particular genre which
fascinated us because in a way it gave
us an itch with no preconceptions in
mind and it's a wealth Hub the largest
in the world for Citibank and it's
situated in Singapore
uh right beside the Apple Store and the
conventions that we're trying to
question were basically there are quite
a few but in in summary the three main
ones what is the nature of contemporary
luxury especially when it comes to you
know wealth management and a clientele
that's very used to
um incredibly beautiful and and
expensive things how do we celebrate the
sight and its challenges was a very
difficult unusual site and then uh is
the gap between the front of house where
the clients are met in the back of house
where the the relationship managers and
staff who service the clients work
there's usually a huge gap between these
two is it bridgeable uh and can the
people working behind the stage and in
the frontal stage be really treated the
same way so the first question what is
the nature of contemporary luxury uh can
it be especially in the banking scenario
more than just like boring chandeliers
and and marble that's site was very
challenging there was this huge glass
Atrium space very hard to make actual
space and meeting rooms inside it so
that was one of the huge challenges and
then the back of house spaces are
usually horrible cubicles how do we make
it and move it Beyond fluorescent light
and this with the same kind of budgets
and not burst the budget for the project
so the solution let me walk you through
it now so that's the building from
across the street and you see it takes
up four floors of the upper levels and
you can see that big glass Atrium there
the two main public levels one for one
layer of kind of private banking client
and then another one for a higher tier
so when you first arrive there's this
sense of containment uh organic flow
that guides you naturally through and
into the space beyond and it's inside in
anticipation of this usually you have in
your mind already a particular
experience but then when you walk
through this a very interior like space
you actually emerge and come out into
this sort of garden uh where there's
this poetic balance between something
that's very Lush and Primal with the
tropicality that represents Singapore
together with this very careful chisel
choreographed planter boxes which lead
you through the space is very organic
and we we chose this attitude to take
because firstly we felt that the green
was uh incredible
symbol a new symbol for how wealth could
be manifested uh it's sustainable it's
responsible it's done in ways which
doesn't harm others and the environment
around it and we thought this is an
appropriate and relevant new symbol for
wealth we wanted to create this
environment not just because it was nice
and because Singapore is a city in the
garden but because it stands for
something greater than itself and we
hope that that would sort of set the
tone for the discussions that would
happen uh these meeting Parts which are
self-sustained rooms with air
conditioning AV sound systems
soundproofing and you can have meetings
there in private and the clients love to
meet in here you feel like secure and
and have a lot of privacy but you also
deep inside the space and you can look
at the Garden around you the space
really transforms at night and it
becomes a lot more sort of Moody and
dramatic and there are lots of events
here help for the clients at night the
spaces can be transformed into cocktail
event spaces and one of the other
Innovations was having a bar in the
center of a wealth management Hub which
almost never happens it's much more
lifestyle driven in this case and the
clients were very open to these ideas
and embrace them
uh and as we move through the layers the
upper layers for another tier of private
wealth client uh even higher one and the
scale changes it's more intimate uh the
spaces are for two to three rather than
larger groups uh the detailing is uh
slightly more articulated and intricate
and all of the Care uh represented
allows you also to sort of build this
sense of anticipation as you look down
into the garden spaces below and we
fondly call this uh sort of the NV
Corner we knew psychologically that the
people below will aspire to become
clientele members of the space above and
this was a way to solve like trumpet
that you have arrived by standing at
this corner and looking down below
so moving through the rest of the space
just assortment of seating and meeting
areas and also I just want to quickly
show you how we bridge the gap between
what you see now as the front of house
spaces and the next slide showing the
back of house spaces and there's this
almost seamless translation although the
material palette and budget for this was
you know not even close to the front of
house spaces the entire Vibe feeling
with the Botanical aspects the openness
uh the variety of seating really just
translates and makes the person working
at this facility not feel like what they
do behind the scenes is any less
important than when they're upfront
serving the customers I just want to end
with showing you that Beyond The Glitz
and the finished product lots of
challenges this project face many one of
them was the very complex detailing of
the pods and the Planters and the pods
were themselves mini buildings uh almost
like architecture with structure with
mechanical and Engineering Systems all
integrated it's just a room a single
room like a like a ute or a like a tent
but it was it's the full fully
functioning uh self-supporting building
and it took a lot of detailing to figure
out also the complexity of how to make
sure the plants were designed to be
easily changed out to not look like they
were in Parts but it looked seamless how
the Planters had to have fixed modules
so that we didn't run into too much
complexity with too much variety how
each species had to be perfectly suited
for the conditions that we had inside
this space
and also uh we had to do all kinds of
inspections even for the plant
arrangements and all of this happened as
you can see during covet and it was
incredibly challenging because the
construction was super fast tracked and
also Material supplies and contractors
had to be managed in spite of all the
restrictions so this was amazing feat
and it wasn't just the designers and the
clients obviously a whole bunch of
people and this I just wanted to show
especially for students just to give you
an impression when you join the
profession as a designer you're not
walking alone you're working with all
kinds of other Consultants acoustic
Consultants lighting Consultants
engineering Consultants people who
measure the sustainability of your
project you work with a whole bunch of
Builders who are super skilled you'll
learn so much from them more than you
will learn in school sometimes and then
you also work with a whole bunch of
suppliers and you can see the
never-ending list of people that we work
with and this is just a simple set of
them so it's it's really quite amazing
and of course you have you know
brilliant photographers who also capture
your your Project's images and all of
this I think comes from inspiration from
above because all of us are gifted in
particular ways and we're just very
thankful as designers to have been
gifted in this particular way so with
that I thank you and hand the time back
thank you very much Colin for sharing
about the city wealth Hub it was truly
inspiring to hear about some of the
thought process behind the design of the
space and it's also very nice to explore
the space through your photos as well
since I'm clearly not in that high
Network clientele group yet yeah and
right now it is time for our q and a
session so for that I'm going to pass
the toss over to our moderator for today
we have so for those of you who would
like to ask our panel of speakers today
any questions regarding maybe their
presentation or anything really
regarding spatial and interior design
please feel free to click on the Q and A
tab below to submit your questions and
our speakers or try their very best to
try and answer them in the session later
on but for now I have a little
introduction about our moderator we have
who is an experienced lecturer with a
decade of experience working in design
and design education he is currently
leading a dynamic team of Educators at
Singapore Polytechnic to inspire nurture
and to grow futures facial designers he
is trained in Singapore and the United
Kingdom and he's an office Bearer with
the Society of interior designer
Singapore he's an accredited interior
designer of the Singapore interior
design accreditation scheme as well plus
a chartered member of the royal town
planning Institute in the UK so with
that would like to welcome jutsia Colin
and Park
thank you so much Juliana
so my name is a big thank you to tsg for
having me as well as if our speakers
join us today I think it's a real
privilege especially for the students to
really hear about the journeys that our
designers go through I think a lot of
people see the end result right and they
see all these are PDA winners but I
think it's very hard for me to hear
um all all the fourth week let's today
talk about their Journey what are some
of the challenges right and then Colleen
was also talking about constraints or
which people don't see right we see the
beautiful pictures and we think you know
it's an easy job to get it done
um really thank you and I think um so
far we've heard really a lot about the
dialogue between our designers right in
terms of their work their process the
vision and the outcomes so I think
that's very rich and something that we
don't normally get access to so
um let's in view of time let's let's
move forward and I I thank DSG again for
making my life easier with the pole and
we know who is what the tribe has spoken
and what they want so feel free to add
whatever questions that you have and put
in the chat room maybe we can start off
first interestingly all our four
speakers today are all architecturally
trained and then if we we heard about
the transition from for example for
Colleen right began not even in spatial
it was photography you've got stage and
then you move into uh
spatial and maybe other question I can
put off is what what are some of the
strengths and pitfalls of coming from
architectural understanding of space so
first part and maybe the second part
which are what audience is interested
about is there a difference between
spatial design and interior design
right so maybe you want to tap your your
brains on this so two parts the first
um are there strengths and pitfalls of
coming from an architectural background
doing interior design spatial design and
is there any difference uh to you in
terms of spatial design and interior
design yeah so over to park and calling
anyone wants to start off this
call in
we seem not doing quite a bit so maybe
if Colin if you'd like to share some of
your thoughts about your background the
little figure on the dashboard of a car
yeah nodding a lot
um I I think actually the question is
phrased very in a very interesting way
are there any drawbacks uh it seems like
that's already a bias integrated into
the inherent in the question
um I would say actually the opposite
um
there it has been said that architecture
is really the mother of of design uh and
and however you interpret it it seems to
suggest that architecture uh and the way
one thinks about problem solving or
create the process of Creation in
architecture is something that is so
fundamental and Upstream that it can
also apply govern control or influence
the other mediums uh which uh we all
know to be also creative Outlets like
you know interior design for instance
spatial design product design even
branding and I've generally approached
um my training as an architect as a
foundation course like a very long
Foundation course but it's been a
foundation because uh
into the building blocks for
establishing a way to see the world and
to tackle to tackle the issues which
um you might encounter when you design
almost anything
and we've had the privilege and I think
part two uh and I know Josh and Ching
for sure they showed a book and they
show products and they obviously do
architecture as well as space we've also
had the privilege of working
multi-disciplinarily and I found that my
architecture training allows me to
almost hold intention quite a number of
different aspects of design
and deal with them in a thoughtful and
intelligent way uh so I think to begin
with it's a it's a it's a big leg up but
does it mean that everyone needs to have
that kind of background to handle
special design well the answer is no
because uh in a way special design uh
even more so than architecture I feel is
a balance between the cerebral kind of
part of your mind and the sort of
sensory more
phenomenological part of your of your
being meaning it's not just about
solving a problem rationally it's about
also how something really makes you feel
and how you emote and and the the
experience that that you are enveloped
in is very critical and sometimes I
think maybe Architects don't do that as
well because a lot of what we do uh
almost has to be dealt with in such a uh
with such precision and also in
accordance to regulations which are so
overwhelming at times I think
is much more of an expert in that regard
than I am you know and sometimes these
constraints uh
uh maybe at the expense of
the purity of maybe celebrating an
experience in a very visceral way
thanks so much for that maybe pop any
thoughts about what Colleen said
I agree
and your own journey in terms of uh what
are your thoughts about uh coming from
an architectural background in relation
to spatial design
well I think if you're asking a larger
question whether architectural degree is
a prerequisite for uh success in design
field then surely is not
[Music]
um
where spatial design again we're talking
about the following question was the
difference between spatial design
interior design so there are many layers
to the whole industry Elementary layer
to the process and the up huge volume of
projects that do not allow intervention
and spatial design that the society need
people to serve that aspect as well
and due to budget due to space
constraint even down to the simplest
living space that is bad and you just
need to dress it up and that is when you
go to a different spectrum of interior
design versus how we evolve into
interior spatial design or into interior
architecture design or architectural
design whichever so
I think if one is concerned about being
in the design field without
architectural degree are you handicapped
no I think the volume of work is huge
and we need all sorts of people to take
care of different aspects of the whole
industry yeah having architecture degree
surely open a certain aspect of the
business that without which you can't
get in namely architecture that's one
and also the knowledge to deal with a
bit more complex brief where you need to
touch the structure you need to touch
the mechanical and then to shift things
around having architectural training
that helps
yeah and now of course the difference
between spatial design is it a new
meaningful tech line to it I don't think
it's many sorry meaningless tech line to
it no I don't think it's meaningless I
think it's sort of give a different
uh understanding to what interior design
does besides decorating the surfaces so
it does have real meaning behind trying
to call it a different name special
design
one thing I've enjoyed doing uh spatial
design wise which I feel originates from
my training
um to see things in at a fundamental
level uh is to be able to challenge the
way we
conventionally understand space so I
mean the fancy Temple is typology right
uh and we all have archetypes or
typologies in our minds about a lot of
things like for instance it's not just
about desired it's about let's say uh
relationships you know if you go on a
date to the guide page or the girl pay
you do open the door I mean like all
these archetypes of like what
conventional Behavior should be like uh
is constantly called in the question
right as we as we are evolving as a
culture uh and we type at the spatial
level what I find helpful when you begin
to understand it at that level is that
the spatial designer has a role and can
play the
um
can diagnose what at that particular
moment in time let's say today you're
designing for a particular client in a
particular place uh what the most
appropriate and relevant response is and
whether the existing types or archetypes
or typologies are able to
satisfy that need and if not that's
where the fund begins that's when you
can sort of shift or metamorphosize or
or evolve what exists or you can remake
completely what exists especially uh
when things aren't good enough like I
don't know about par and I suspect it's
true for him too but what drives me a
lot is that I'm just never
satisfied with a lot of the things that
I come across uh and inherently I always
say like this can be better maybe I
don't always know why or how but does
this uh innate criticality not in a in a
in a negative way but in a very
constructive way that the world around
us and the things that we do can be done
better they can be experienced better
they can be managed better uh our
experiences of them whether it's the
home which you spend a lot of time in or
the office or the school or the
restaurant or wherever you're finding
yourself right so
in a way I think uh the notion of
spatial designer if you really wanted to
dig to the heart of it I would really
say hey think of itself as an
experiential designer you know like what
is the best experience you're trying to
create and and space and architecture
and and product and everything else
Acoustics and music are just tools that
you employ to enable yourself to create
the best experience possible yeah
thank you so much for that yeah
um I I think we we see
um you know part was early on mentioning
talking about the architect the interior
archetype the interior designer The
Stylist you know we we put labels and we
try to understand the roles or the
support role that you're supposed to be
but what I hear is that not through the
platform of architecture just like Paul
was talking about this GPA paper and how
that's this critical thinking that's
this dialogue right and how you approach
the project I think today we've seen
through all four of the designers it's
really questioning the brief right so
like uh for parties talking about the NT
office you've got classroom in the
basement calling yourself you're also
talking about no master pack of house be
like a factory right and then how do we
extend that experience
um for the customer into the backgrounds
for our people as well and if you look
at George and shin you know they're
designing this intervention for the
Sunbird right and really how the role of
the designer is not just typical but
really understanding the brief and
moving it software so I would like to
say that project that the the school
should have won uh more Awards than it
has because it's a brilliant brilliant
project and I think that designing like
what he has done and what Shing and Josh
have done designing educational
facilities is one of the most meaningful
things you can do because when you
change someone's mindset at a young uh
Point early stage in their in their
development uh where they are young and
fertility can be sort of like a shaped
right it's much more impactful in
creating uh an adult who sees the world
differently and who can question in a
constructive way the world rather than
trying to teach you know someone who's
already gone through 20 30 years of
their life so I think educational spaces
are one of the most important spaces to
design to be honest
yeah and I think it has the most uh
regulations as well we don't see here
but I'm sure there are a lot of behind
the scenes elements to comply and work
with yeah because there are
preconceptions of what is good and
whatever should be right yeah yeah yeah
so show the unique conventions but that
needs to be constantly uh provoked and
and like discussions about the help
right as long as does that openness do
that conventions as a starting point is
nothing wrong I really cannot stand it
when a designer said oh uh when asked
why did you do that and then the
designer goes oh because I wanted to be
different law I think that's ridiculous
because being different and having
novelty is meaningless uh it's only
meaningful when the convention needs to
be Revisited there are many good
conventions that work and you should not
change it right yeah but there's so many
they were there for a reason to begin
with yeah yes on the same note I I also
get upset when the guys tell me why what
husband why are you doing this they say
oh because the regulation dictated
without questioning how to reinterpret
it so it's just knowing how to push the
boundary for good reason
yes and not stay within and not doing it
just to be different you know yes due to
your point part it's about trying to
distill what the regulation intention is
right is it human safety is it to allow
for shading is it to allow for something
and can you achieve that goal through
another means that's really that's
really you know what we should be doing
but of course there are so many of these
it's hard to do that for everything like
like you mentioned there's just a lot of
constraints right and I mean it also
Echoes what we're saying here also
Echoes what Josh and shin were talking
about that there's no typical user and
then how we try to fit right the
solution won't be a one solution fit or
yeah yeah in fact uh I think that's
interesting because uh we we don't as
much as part does uh we don't design for
Unique end users as much I mean our our
designs typically are are more for an
imagined user right let's say a hotel or
a commercial project whereas when you
have the privilege of doing it for a
specific person then really that Mantra
of there is no typical user it can be
you called into into play because then
you can design for someone and their
eccentricities and their preferences not
so much their tastes right but their
habits and their rituals and their
Lifestyles and how can you design a
space that's perfect for that unique
individual so yeah it is true when you
can afford to do it it's it's the only
way to go so a good point you talk about
is being able to afford doing this and
because you all have a years of
experience and you've been on this
journey with many different projects and
all maybe any any thoughts for our
students who are often in the audience
um how can they come to terms of this
right because here we're talking about a
dialogue you're pushing certain agendas
with enlightened clients
um but for of our current students what
do you think can better prepare them
um to uh we look forward to such a
uh Outlook of being able to practice
this uh later on in their career but any
tips upfront what should they be doing
to prepare themselves for their next
stage when they graduate
I think having a point of view is
incredibly important and uh it sounds
like an obvious thing but I think when
you drill down deep not many of us have
very clear points of view on things or
or more importantly I mean you're kind
of a point of view on everything uh
because you you haven't had the time to
encounter and process and and and and
reflect right but how do you how do you
ensure that the students of today have
the ability and tools at their disposal
to form form points of view because
without a point of view without internal
Compass uh then you are Guided by
everything else external you know like
the rules that exist or the conventions
that exist or the opinions that exist or
the trends that exist or you know what
social media is telling you I think if
we had a whole generation of students
who have the ability to form points of
view and those points of view obviously
grounded in compassion and and a sense
of
it's not a self-driven point of view
it's a point of view that that manages
to exist within and harmony with the
community around them then you're not
just creating better designers but
you're creating better everything you're
you're creating better consumers I mean
if you have better clients and and
patrons and government authority figures
all of this adds and contributes towards
a happy ecosystem it will be the most
frustrating if you have talented
designers but incredibly uh dim clients
or incredibly obstinate uh authority
figures because you know it's a
multi-faceted cycle that requires so
many parties to to uh
mind Mill and ask difficult questions
together and seek Solutions together for
the best projects really I mean the
project that part showed impossible we
bought an open uh client right the
project I showed impossible without
um a client who inherently wanted to
have something new and Innovative and
relevant for today rather than sick of
the same old same old right so
inherently those clients are already
geared either they had to be steered or
they were already geared to be receptive
to this uh without image I think you
know all our talent is unless you're as
you're independently wealthy and can
fund your own projects
that's when there's no resistance so
maybe on that point thank you so much
for that and maybe practically how any
any could you share with us how did
either part or close in yourself how did
you overcome the kinds notion right
because you have these constraints and
then we have a question here you know
how do designers validate their Concepts
before implementing them so maybe for
the projects that you've shown if you
can share with us what what were some of
your what what do you do to convince the
client or overcome that sort of
stereotype of what a classroom or office
should be
well I think something that we often
forget young designers is validating
concept it could be as simple using a
masking tapping out the dimensional flaw
standing in the box and see how it feels
like of course on a bigger scale of
course models and even full-scale
mock-up models that are all methods
but
according correctly pointed out it the
style has had the Stars has to be
aligned for a truly great project to
happen
but I think it doesn't happen by chance
or rather the chance could be helped if
you embark on the right track of your
career earlier
that for example as a firm if you had go
in the right direction you had the right
expiration you
a bit more selective and push yourself a
little harder the product will come up
will show itself and your track
they're more likely to attract that kind
of client eventually who look to you to
give you more space
or not
um and it makes your life easier to try
to convince a client for what you're
trying to do having done something
incrementally better over the years
yeah yeah that's absolutely right uh it
takes a commitment to a certain
philosophy on ethos and if if let's say
money making was your bottom line uh
okay firstly as business owners right
part of myself will really tell you that
there are multiple bottom lines that we
constantly have to uphold because money
is not only Bottom Line work life
balance and and how we care for our
staff is another bottom line uh the
quality of our work and the outcomes
that it generates is also another bottom
line right so like it's not open online
so he's absolutely right in saying that
if you don't make a commitment early
to sing I will sacrifice a for B Because
B is more important if you don't do that
then you will just be jostled by the win
per se like whatever life brings to you
or whatever life throws at you and you
won't filter it because you're not
conscious you're not sentient you don't
have the the point of view that we're
talking about you don't have that so
you'll just be like just reactive or
reactive you know if you're lucky yeah
if you're not then you just so then but
that's different it's not like everyone
needs to have that it's fine if you
don't but what we're saying is if you
want to generate work that is eventually
meaningful on these multiple levels and
is relevant and it changes the way maybe
people live and experience certain key
things in their life then you have to do
and it's a long journey isn't it I mean
it takes decades to to do so I'm curious
when did your point of view develop when
was the inkling on that moment of the
point of view was it in school was it
you know when or you know like partly
was it because you started your own firm
and then some of the things you saw
certain patterns in the words that you
were doing because I think
point of view you is was there a Eureka
moment or was there patterns that you
started trying to decide yeah
in your engine yeah for me you need to
start working and you try to look back
as often as possible to try to recharge
where you have been and if things had
been in the right direction
Colleen is talking about not being able
to have your point of view too early
and
that you need to develop that by being
very open to all sorts of compartmental
information but at the same time be
selective and actually want us to become
your call of your designer principle and
not just absorbing everything I just
call whatever you hear of course for me
when we had the real Focus that was
again during the financial crisis so we
were very busy we were doing very well
since 1999 to
2007 but when the crisis hit
I realized that within a few months all
Reserve had run dry and the firmware
have been closed if not for the savior
of a project and we try to imagine that
you know how could we be successful for
so many years and yet
it wouldn't survive Point crisis so we
start to question on whether we're doing
think the right way
and um we're catering to the right kind
of product where we workflow and how do
we position ourselves and do we go for
volume instead of going for value and
and this is when we realized that okay
design design with depth and intention
and design with thoughts those are the
things that will bring you projects that
will Cruise you through in the worst of
time
thank you so much for that yeah Colin
any thoughts
yeah yeah I'll go I'll I'll get circle
around with that in a sec but just to to
Rift over at Park saying
um I mean there's a certain sense of
pragmatic pragmatism that a business
owner who isn't uh born of a Golden
Spoon in your mouth uh has to undertake
uh and although we have shown you the
best of our work they're also I mean at
least from our point of view there are
projects where we have strive to do
things and we haven't maybe necessarily
achieve them but we've had to do them
anyway because they were a means to a
long-term end uh there were steps that
went to be taken necessarily uh which
built us up in terms of resilience it
built Us in terms of experience but
maybe it didn't build us in terms of
like award-winning projects or maybe it
didn't build us up in in you know in the
kind of like uh flashy media ready
project but it made us more well-rounded
it gave us skill building opportunities
Etc so nothing is nothing is
um you know like a good a good Chef in
the kitchen no ingredient is is
um wasted everything goes into making
something maybe you don't see it as the
style of the dish but it's there
somewhere for myself I think it's a bit
of nurture and a bit of nature so
um I remember two like influential
people in my life so the nature business
I think by Nature there is a inherent
very strong uh spatial creative uh
Spirit uh that I see I see my father
although he was an engineer he didn't
really have a chance to express it but
it was very inherent in him and I think
you know it's it's sort of genetic in in
some degree but what unlocked it was
meeting a few people so one of them was
uh you know my sister was very she is a
very creative person and uh she's older
than me also and the thing she exposed
me to really helped and there's also
another couple uh who one is uh was a
photographer then and another was a
fashion editor uh who really a lot a
whole world of non-mainstream creative
outlets for me in terms of alternative
movies literature music and none of them
were spatial you know but they were all
they all influenced the way I saw the
world and felt that well and then I
realized that through that I began to
see that what uh the the previous
exposure I had to things when I returned
to those things I realized I was not
happy with them anymore I realized that
there was a elevated census sensitivity
and an elevated sensibility towards
things and there was this constant no
way can be better things can be better
things can be more more on point or
things can have more essence you know or
distilled to mean more and I think this
was really because of some of these key
influences then of course along the way
educationally I had a few amazing uh
professors uh two in particular one one
was also a Harvard grad and she was
super influential in making me see uh
designs through the different scales and
then another was you know an architect
who was old enough to work with Walter
The Group PSN okay maybe a few of us
will understand that that reference by
Walter group this is one of the great
modernists and uh you know my professor
worked with him and uh was was
incredibly insightful so they were along
the way uh you know to our audience
about their whether you are established
like Park is or whether you are a newbie
and you know you're just starting your
career you really need to be incredibly
open uh and curious and to gravitate
towards people who can influence you
this particular way and and I think the
reason why they took to me those those
key influences in my life was because I
possessed this sense of I want to learn
I'm just very hungry and I'm just
innately curious about things they're
not they were not going to reach out if
they didn't see someone who was willing
to soak up all they had to give an offer
I think so I think you Avail yourself to
these uh influences and you need to keep
yourself sort of very open to them as
well and it's a two-way street and
without those uh you can't grow and
maybe the struggle is in our older age
developmentally it's hard to find those
main cause but I still find people I
speak with even peers who do different
things from me very inspiring
um
it's a lot easier to just cruise with it
yes yeah yeah then you just try to see
how you can enjoy all of this so-called
tiring process where one would
constantly go to gym to push oneself and
get Runners high and stuff so if you
feel that learning is tiring but it's
have got a high when you learn and when
you
change your mind and you have to form a
certain perspective and get that let it
be what drives you then that could be
the energy that you burn getting there
yeah yeah thank you so much yeah I think
the key words I'm really hearing is
about
um process and growing right and I think
a lot of our students these days
um they they want to strive in the chief
but maybe maybe a bit impatient and they
want it now so I I think my key takeaway
is really um putting myself in the
driver's seat right so being aware being
open and having control and being
reflective so to move forward because I
think some of the questions are looking
at very uh technical things you know
like what software what moment my
portfolio look better but I think Colin
has shared you know about point of view
the critical thinking being able to then
understand your own journey and then
pinpointing or picking up some of these
similarities and having an alternate
point of view so that when you approach
a project it's really something that is
it fits the needs uh rather and it fits
the needs and it's meaningful as opposed
to just making something pretty or
something different for the sake of
shocking people yeah I think that's
great maybe let's move on because the
chart has spoken and I'm just like full
of time maybe let's move on to maybe a
question that you know the professionals
uh would would like some input from and
let's move on to the notion about
sustainability and designing for the
future and you know we all heard about
you know there are many constraints many
things that are tuggling at each project
so maybe if you could share with us what
are some of maybe
um your tips you have about juggling uh
the various needs but including
sustainable elements in uh and so that's
one and maybe
um how meaningful do you think this
sustainability element in view of
climate change yeah because interior is
one part right or spatial design is just
one part do you think what you're doing
is enough
um to make that change as well yeah so
maybe some some thoughts about that so
first off any tips about you know how do
you approach sustainability or include
sustainable aspects in your design and
then second any thoughts about that in
relation to the bigger scale of the
interior and then you've got the
architecture and then you've got the
whole Urban Precinct and all yeah any
any thoughts and any tips on that yeah
maybe I'd like to answer the second
question first because I think the first
one is a bit Downstream
but maybe the second one sheds more like
I I this is kind of controversial to say
because uh it's a bit like biting the
hand that feeds but I feel that
sustainability inherently is to read is
through the reduction of consumption and
a constant change in discarding and
renewing uh because it has been built
into our psyche especially uh
the last maybe a decade and a half of
um of constant renewal through making
things inherently irrelevant uh all
through poor and sort of mediocre
quality uh products or experiences on
the whole
um
so in other words sustainability I feel
comes through things which are much more
purposefully designed for long-term
usage rather than disposability and
renewal all the time uh and what does
that mean I mean it doesn't mean that we
have less work to do but it means that
the work we do needs to be much better
and much better considered so instead of
like being paid x amount to do let's say
being paid one dollar to do 10 jobs we
really should be paid uh five dollars to
do two jobs and make those two jobs even
if it takes much longer to accomplish
last five times longer and that to me is
the nature of true success
sustainability because it's almost
paying lip service to sustainability if
you have the same amount of consumption
even if you use better yes of course we
need to use things that are more
sensitively sourced and
um are more sustainable inherently but
it's the Quantum of what we are
consuming that is the issue and how fast
we are churning through it all uh a
because a lot of the stuff we designed
these days is designed to be sort of
disposed and replaced right a lot of our
products I mean why do we need a new
phone every two years is ridiculous but
what of what new offer does it offering
does it really give you right same to do
with renovation of homes same to do with
architecture seem to do with fashion
Fashions are almost the worst uh uh you
know culprit of that so it's very
inherent in our mindsets right uh so I
think if we design things that really
were designed to last right and possess
quality true quality right through
materials through thoughtful design
through very well well considered
implementation and craft and those
things because they're so cyan they're
so well done you don't go and tear down
a masterpiece you don't like say let's
just throw this away because it's a
masterpiece this is an heirloom and
that's I think that would be true truly
much more sustainable along with the
other measures that we take for the
renewal that we need to do I'm not
saying we know it's not important but
but it needs to be much more
um a much more measured
yeah up any thoughts on sustainability
or what a college share yeah I think the
question of whether are we doing enough
um
there's no measurement to it and I think
this lifestyle and this whole attitude
towards what is wasteful what it's not
it's something that have to evolve over
time it's not a matter of campaign and
therefore whether how much campaign do
we do are we doing enough campaign of it
and
I I I think we are going along the right
track
there will be implementation they will
look back and realize that that was the
worst thing to have done for
sustainability even though that was done
in the name of sustainability for
example
um so
um
a bit skeptical with some of the
specific prescriptions because they are
probably driven by a lot of lobbyists
who have got the bottom line to try to
support plastic for example or for some
time they were the
best thing in the world because there
are multiple usage of a certain wasted
material
and it because then they will try to
push the volume up by suggesting it to
be thrown away each time you know and
again that is for the profit driven but
if you go back to what how you
originally started
I think it was good it was it was using
wasted material to do something that
could last a long time and to be reused
over and over again
so I I think we try to get attitude
right and let it
grow through the generation but
uh
yeah it's not nothing to be measured now
thank you for that I think in terms of
um there are always different benchmarks
right what was uh seen as a good effort
10 years ago maybe now it's seen as or
not enough anymore and I I really like
the point that Colleen was talking about
about how it's a holistic solution uh I
think even in school we are teaching
ways to be sustainable there are
Frameworks that we assess our buildings
and Interiors to say that it's
sustainable but I think if you talk
about the role of the designer we talk
about lasting design right we talk about
uh it's considered it's user friendly
how do people use the caters to people's
needs and I like the idea that Colleen
talked about and how it's value right
you talk about the heirloomance value
and you know nowadays
you talk about fashion you know this
shirt okay I've won a few times it's a
bit out of shape throw right and what is
the value that you have today and I
think everything around us that that is
the designer someone had gone through to
think about how to uh how people use it
how it's manufactured how people
experience it
um but really it also depends on how we
evaluate our own personal uh values and
how we attach to it before we actually
uh follow up with whatever actions to
throw to keep to reuse recycle so I
really like that motion and idea about
um the role of the designer how the
designer has the Outlook and it's a
holistic one and I guess it's that
holistic Outlook that really juggles and
comes to terms with all of these
different aspects so that the outcome
not only is it usable not only does it
cater to different users and their needs
but it's also something that's value
because it's truly something that people
really enjoy using that's something that
they experience yeah
not because of it of the sentiment
reality of it but because of his
inherent worth you see so uh when I say
hello my I obviously mean it in a in
sort of a figurative way not a literal
way but I think it would be hard-pressed
for you to you take a magazine that you
read once and then you throw away but if
I give you a leather bound book with you
know uh you know beautiful
um stitches technology and stitches
you're not going to just you're going to
think three times before you throw that
away right yeah so it's not but it
doesn't necessarily translate into
expensive things like obviously not all
of us kind of fought the equivalent of
that the book to live in right but still
even with materials that are sustainable
and inexpensive you can craft a space
that is very very valuable uh not
through expense uh in terms of materials
but value of the idea and the experience
living in it so yeah I do I do think in
the long term
if we are to survive for another you
know Millennium and our great great
grandchildren are to enjoy a world that
we enjoy today uh then we will not so
much have to enjoy less or live less
well but we just have to live more well
over a long period of Time Versus very
short Snippets of you know uh fleeting
sort of of gestures uh that we redispose
of so quickly
yes I I think
the the key takeaway for me is that
think of it in terms of the long game be
it as a student be it as a designer and
whatever we do and construct you know it
has a life of its own and it goes beyond
um us and hopefully for the field
projects and I think
um the other important word that I
picked up and keeps resonating with me
is earlier you talked about that having
empathy and I'm sure Josh and sharing
some of their projects it's a very
ignition and a unique part of society
dedicated to right and those I'm sure
not only the users but even the parents
of the children they would really value
those faces because it's so rare and so
few in between as well right yeah so I
really think I really learned a lot
today I really want to thank Colin and
part for the sharing and so I think due
to time I think we'll end off here but
um I understand there are a few other
questions
um but what we will work on is that I
understand Josh and Ching are not
without yesterday but DSG will follow up
and in the email at the end of the
session you'll be able to get some of
their inputs and some of their thoughts
as well a big thank you to call in a big
thank you to Paul and I really
appreciate the audience I think there
are a lot of questions very interesting
questions that have come in Fast and
Furious and hopefully I try to cover as
much as I could but thank you so much to
everyone
pleasure
so thank you so much once again to Dear
Hawk as well as Colin for sharing your
experience with our audience we did have
quite a number of questions and we did
end up covering a range of topics as
well as questions to cater to our
student groups and Professionals in this
webinar today so hopefully you've taken
away a little something from our panel
this afternoon so for our audience out
there we'll really love to hear from you
okay we'll appreciate it if you could
help us to complete a short survey on
this webinar to help us to improve on
our future programs and for our SIDS
members just a gentle reminder for you
to fill in this survey form with your
relevant details to qualify for their
CPD points please do expect a waiting
period of about three weeks for your CPD
points to be credited finally I have to
tell you about this special giveaway
that we're doing where you can win
yourself an exclusive Singapore design
week 2022 t-shirt plus an exclusive hard
copy of the PDA 2020 public education
when you share with us your greatest
takeaway from this webinar shouldn't be
difficult we covered quite a fair bit so
please do scan the QR code for the
survey form and if you would like to
find out more about the various upcoming
programs at the national Design Center
please do also scan the QR code that you
see on the screen right now
and with that we have come to the end of
the session today so I just want to
thank you all once again thank you to
our speakers thank you to our moderator
and of course our audience for spending
your Thursday afternoon with us we
definitely look forward to seeing you at
our future events have a very good
evening ahead and goodbye
laughs
[Music]